القوات الجويه الامريكيه تكشف عن الوان
الطائره الرئاسيه الجديده الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن احتفظ باللونين الابيض والازرق
الفاتح ولبين اختارهما كندي قبل اكثر من
سته عقود لطائرتين قيد البناء تخلى بايدن
عن مخطط الوان اختارها سلف وهدول ترامب
وهما اللونين الاحمر والابيض والازرق
والداكن والذي اراد من خلالها ترامب تشكيل
العالم الامريكي على جسم طائره
على فكره اير فورس 1 هو لقب طائره التي
تقل رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
دائما تتميز بطلاء ابيض وازرق فاتح ليس
لاسباب استراتيجيه او وطنيه لكن ببساطه
لانه الازرق يعني كان اللون المفضل رئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقتها كندي
الطائره كلفت 8 ملايين دولارات ودخلت خدمه
عام 1962 استخدمها ثلاثه رؤساء قبل ان
تتقاعد كليا نادين عام 98 هي اليوم في
المتحف الوطني للقوات الجويه الامريكيه في
اوهايو واذا عدنا لتصميم هذه الطائره فهو
للمصمم العالمي ريمول الايقوني لطائره
الرئاسه وضلو نفسه تقريبا يعني حتى في
النصح النسخ اللاحقه من طائره كندي لكن
ترامب كان يريد الوان مختلفه للطائرتين
الجديتين فوقتها اثارت هذه الفكره طبعا
جدلا كبيرا الاعتراض ليس لانه كان يريد
التخلي عن التقليد المتبع او الاعتبارات
جماليه لكن اللون الازرق الداكن في تصميم
ترامب كان سيرفع درجه حراره المحرك يعني
مش بس مساله الوان كمان مساله سلامه فهذا
يتطلب لمزيد من اختبارات تاهيل اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه بطبيعه الحال